what's up guys welcome to screen junkies
don't worry I won't be annoying any
celebrities or taking bags off anyone's
heads today instead we're talking
guardians of the galaxy the trailer just
dropped it looked really cool it was
funny and had a lot attitude to it but
really who are these guardians of the
galaxy that you speak of we brought in a
super cool panel to tell us and break it
down first he's a good friend of the
show he's the writer of Manhunter
Captain America
Batwoman it's mr. mark and Draco hello
how Mark thanks for being here my
pleasure and this man is the head of
geek scape they just launched geek scape
TV and look for his new digital comic
Miami Vice coming out soon Jonathan
London
so the first guardians the galaxy
trailer just came out oh I know what you
guys think it felt like it needed to be
about 10 seconds tighter it just felt
like that the joke kind of fell flat
that the and I know they wanted to show
the some of the special effects and show
the world and it's obviously working is
I'm in the minority Jonathan I know you
liked it quite bad I liked it um just
the fact that this movie is this is huge
for me oh that's a very cool thing a
guardian a $200,000,000 guardian of the
galaxy movie you know I mean like who
would have thought this what we would
ever exist so I had a smile from ear to
ear the entire time watching this it did
have a lot of jobs to do I mean how to
introduce the characters but also had to
introduce the tone the tone has to be
weird and also has to be cosmic so
there's not a superhero this trailer a
lot of people are gonna realize only
when they're sitting in the seats and
the movies starting that it's a Marvel
film I want you to talk to me and talk
to our audience like we mentioned these
guys are not the superheroes that were
used to what - the guardians the galaxy
do the guardians the galaxy originally
were a whole different group of outer
space characters this group is based on
a reboot kinda that Marvel did a few
years back they're just a group of
disparate characters who are kind of you
know they're kind of all different
versions of Han Solo they're kind of out
for their own you know the Firefly
Farscape that sort of totally you know
they're privateers
or if they're in it for themselves but
of course they ultimately Barry they all
clearly do the good thing they got to do
the good thing or else they can't help
yourselves right they're not as badass
as they'd like to present themselves
right right exactly
let's break down who they
are individually whose Chris Pratt
playing he's playing Peter quill
star-lord who is uh kind of he's very
much the Han Solo nathan fillion Firefly
character he's this guy that's out there
and thinks much more of himself than
anyone else as you can tells the joke in
the trailer star-lord who star-lord man
and his star-lord a human is he from
Earth yes yes you feeling human on the
teach from Pasadena
who's Zoe Saldana play she please good
she's just a badass assassin
Columbiana meets the Navi yeah Aaron you
should not be here or I'll kill you so
in the comics she status daughter is
that going to be our whole springboard
into the Avengers and guardians of the
galaxy fan else's daughter in the movie
continuity they haven't spelled but they
do I mean you'll learn a little bit more
about fan OHS and if they actually keep
Thanos on the sidelines for this movie
and Avengers 2 cuz Ultron's the villain
there then it really sets up the
Infinity Gauntlet for Avengers 3 tell me
about the Rocket Raccoon Rocket Raccoon
I think is gonna be the star of the
movie I mean you have a talking raccoon
as a smartass this one in our food he's
the Wolverine of the movie he's got
laser pistols on it you don't want to
call him racoon yeah you don't you
actually actually he's actually a rocket
because he's an alien species that looks
like a raccoon or if you call him a
raccoon he gets really pissed off he was
created back in the late 70s by a guy
named bill Mantlo
who is actually this is a good time to
talk about he was injured in a car
accident in 92 and suffered a closed
brain injury and is in dire financial
need so there are all sorts of sites on
the internet that link to bill Matt
Louis we'll put a link in the comment
section below
that'll be awesome so is uh Vin Diesel
playing a tree those are the two like
voiced characters like rocky racoon is
Bradley Cooper and Vin Diesel is doing
route who's that giant tree thing you
see yeah it's kind of ruses like the
muscle it is a badass yeah he has
rockets back like the two of them are
kind of a team within a team cool
so about Groot though yes because he's
this giant wooden tree creature able to
cool things he only ever says I am Groot
yeah really life but the other cool
thing about him is he can get destroyed
and if there's just a little sliver of
him Rocket will plant him in a planter
and he'll grow back again yeah he can
take care of it I know your wrestling
fan are you excited about wo Yi's
Batista tell me about his character uh
Batista um plays Drax the destroyer
who's basically like the big
losses muscle on the team this guy is
just a badass he's by the one is gonna
pick up you know he's gonna rack up the
biggest body count that's basically it
he's just a badass and you're gonna see
him doing the most damage in the movie
for me awesome I can't wait to see just
the entire team unleash it not only that
but miscommunicate hate each other guys
do not get along oh you know with the
Avengers who are like oh go over here he
Tony take to the sky Thor contain
everyone you know this is gonna be like
what's up did you do that for you
you guys are screwing up oh my
god get over here it's gonna be a
complete mess of a team cool so I feel
like you guys have really schooled us
the guardians of galaxy just a roving
band of mercenary Han Solo types with a
tree that are just going around wrecking
shop and kicking ass and taking names
that's about it yeah awesome cool so
let's talk about the bigger picture it
looks kind of like this is all leading
to the Infinity Gauntlet how will they
get there with these guys in the first
floor movie you see the Infinity
Gauntlet which is this glove that the
different gems go into that Thanos had
from a really successful comic book
series but I think Marvel opening up
their cosmic universe to make it make
the worlds seem larger is going to
dovetail into Avengers 3 I'm assuming
phantoms will be Avengers 3 because I'm
assuming lots of these actress contracts
are ups they're going to use them for
the big bang at the end Kevin Feige did
say that this is intended to be a
standalone film do you think we'll see
these guys pop up later and yes yeah
it's probably going to be a standalone
film but with the open endedness for
sequels you know it's not gonna I don't
think they're all going to die at the
end they're all going to retire but just
by the appearance of the collector and
some of the Infinity gem stuff it ties
in to the Avengers movies what would
ultimately make this movie a total
success for you I don't think this movie
needs to make 400 million dollars to be
considered a hit and it opens up a whole
different corner of the universe we
haven't we've never seen a Marvel movie
that takes place off earth other than
Asgard but as far as hardcore sci-fi
goes so it just opens up there are so
many cosmic characters that they have
that they can open up a whole new series
of franchise what's to keep them from
being as dynamic a company as they could
be ya know it's all gonna help each
other so guys what do you think about
guardians of the galaxy is it gonna flop
or is it gonna pop let us know in the
comments section below best answer gets
a screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
my esteemed panel mark and Draco
Jonathan London thanks for being here
fellas I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter thanks for watching bye bye
would you mind taking the bag off you
take the bag off your head can I take
the bag off your head Wow